et nous accueillons
Bernard
Carole
Thomas
Brigitte
Brigitte pourquoi le rap finalement a
pris cette place dans votre histoire
pourquoi le rap le rap c'était le seul
moment où les autres m'écoutaient et
c'est plus simple de dire je t'aime à
travers un couplet moi le petit
toulousain très timide et pudique j'ai
posé dans mon jardin secret un bon
public je rentrais du lycée il y avait
mon père devant le JT il me disait les
gens sont fous et la société compliqué
je vais vous parler des Birkenstock et
d'ailleurs alors je suis un peu déçu que
tout le monde les a quitté parce que ah
nonop magnifique merci beaucoup parce
que bon pour tous ceux qui seraient
restés
enfermés cet été et bien la pire
catchock ça a été la star de l'été on
l'a vu partout 1 million d'euros c'est
notre chiffre du jour le montant auquel
s'est vendu aux enchères ce pull un pull
de Noël ce qu'on appelle communément un
pull moche sauf que celui-ci a appartenu
à lacesse Diana des moutons blancs sur
un fond rouge et au milieu un mouton
noir message sout subliminal symbolisant
la place de la princesse au sein de la
famille royale 1 million d'euros
c'est